president has declared a national
emergency which seeks to divert eight
billion dollars towards the building of
a us-mexico border wall thank you for
taking a few minutes to jump in on a
very important topic with me here I
wanted to do this video because there's
a lot of biased information out there
and I wanted to break this down from a
purely legal and analytical standpoint
what you probably don't know if you're
watching our channel for the first time
or if you just casually watch the
channel is that I am also a lawyer in
the state of California I passed the bar
exam on my first try and I thought this
was a great opportunity to speak to you
directly about some of the legal
ramifications that are inherent here
what it means for the United States the
United States Constitution and
ultimately what it means for use you
guys are wondering about any of the
references they're all in the
description below so let's get started
so as you may know the president has
declared a national emergency which
seeks to divert eight billion dollars
away from areas previously allocated by
Congress to build a us-mexico border
wall this is very important for a lot of
reasons let's get into it as you've
probably heard the US government just
reopened after the longest shutdown in
his history of 35 days now why was it
shutdown well quite frankly because
Congress couldn't agree on a budget bill
that they knew the president would sign
under article 1 of the Constitution
Congress has the power of the purse
which basically means they have the
power to control the money of the United
States of America now that's their
department that's their branch of
government however they can't pass a
budget bill or a law solely on their own
the balance of powers require that the
president sign off on a bill or a budget
in order for it to become law so here's
where this really starts to matter well
the president signed off on the budget
that budget didn't include the eight
billion dollars of funding that he
wanted to build the us-mexico border
wall so what is he to do if he really
wants to make this happen he either has
to quit and go on or if you're on an
unorthodox guy you can invoke your
national emergency powers
what is required exactly for a president
to be able to declare a national
emergency and what is it first and
foremost a national emergency is a power
that a president can use to basically
give them extra power in a moment of
crisis way back in 1911 Woodrow Wilson
was the first one to declare a national
emergency and after him presidents
really liked it they started declaring
more of them FDR declared a bunch of
them the problem was that at no point
during these declarations did the
president cite relevant statutes which
gave them the authority to declare an
emergency they didn't cite the scope or
for how long an emergency was supposed
to be in effect so it started to get
into unfettered power territory in 1976
Congress passed the national emergencies
act which limits the authority from
which a president can declare an
emergency to about a hundred and thirty
five statutes it also requires that if a
president is to declare an emergency he
must cite one of those statutes as the
basis for his power On February 15th the
president declared his construction
authority from one of these statutes
specifically 10 USC 2808 a I have the
statute right here I'm gonna read it to
you with my handy dandy piece of paper
in the event of a declaration by the
president of a national emergency that
requires the use of the Armed Forces the
Secretary of Defense may undertake and
authorize military construction projects
not otherwise authorized by law which
are necessary to support such use of the
Armed Forces that's what the president
is basing his Authority off of what does
that mean well number one you need the
Armed Forces to be at the border in
order for this to be even relevant
well that's true the Armed Forces are at
the border secondarily the construction
aspect of this statute is supposed to be
in support of the purpose for which the
armed forces are there so given what the
president is citing for his national
emergency authority here the only
question becomes whether his declaration
can be seen as legitimate within the
bounds of this statute now there's
nothing like free market advertising to
get you into the political mindset and
god Bless America because today's
episode is brought to you by Squarespace
that's right they have an all-in-one
platform so whether you're looking to
create a website or claim a domain or
build an online store market a brand
they got you covered they have beautiful
award-winning designer templates and
24/7 customer service I mean who doesn't
like to speak to somebody on the phone
when you call in it's only politics for
that easy
it's also never been easier to do an
online store if you need to keep track
of inventory or if you got Nikko running
for president in 2020 and you need to
keep track of all the shirts that you
sell
Squarespace can help you out is that an
announcement yeah Nikko just announced
so head on over to Squarespace calm to
get started on your free trial today and
when you're ready to launch go to
Squarespace comm slash corridor crew and
get 10% off your first to purchase now
back to that national emergency now as
you may know multiple states have filed
suit in direct opposition to this
emergency declaration so it will
inevitably go to law the court will need
to look at two things number one they
will first need to ask whether or not
the national emergency required the use
of the Armed Forces and number two
whether the building of a border wall is
necessary to support the use of the
Armed Forces they will also look at
precedent this construction Authority
has been used two other times by both
Bush presidents with George W Bush it
was after the attacks of 9/11 and we
sent troops all over the world and the
construction authority was necessary to
support those troops as they went about
the global war on terror
in addition George HW Bush cited this
Authority when Kuwait was first invaded
by Iraq and we needed to intervene and
create infrastructure for our militaries
so that we could stop that from
happening now the courts could very well
rule in favor of the Trump
administration here that wouldn't
surprise me at all in general the courts
defer to the president when it comes to
Authority as the commander in chief but
even if the president is able to do this
just because he can do something we need
to ask ourselves whether or not it's the
right thing to do here's what I mean
we're dealing with a situation where
multiple other departments of the
executive branch the same branch as the
such as Customs and Border Protection
and the Department of Homeland Security
their data shows that since 2000
captures at the border have all gone
down well enforcement of the border has
all gone up that means that border
security is working there is no real way
to sugarcoat that because there is no
other data that supports his opinion as
strongly as he has his opinion it's
completely unprecedented in that sense
unfortunately for all of us
there is very little direction under the
national emergencies act which says how
much of an emergency something actually
needs to be for the use of an emergency
declaration to be considered legitimate
regardless of all that the main problem
is that this politicizes the national
emergency power that's the greatest
threat to the United States here and to
the Constitution Food for Thought thanks
for spending a couple minutes here with
us at corridor digital and I'd love to
hear what your guys opinion is on this
leave a comment below I'll definitely be
taking a look and scrolling through
responding back keep it civil please
please keep it civil that is the one
thing that we need more of thanks for
watching
hey how's it going guess what I just hit
submit on our amazon store front page
for top ten games you can play in your
head by yourself that means on Saturday
March 2nd this book is finally going to
be live and ready to purchase I'm super
excited about it we've been working on
this for almost five years and it's it's
a monumental occasion for me because
I've never released the book we've never
done anything like this I've been
reading the subreddit March last
corridor just asking what's the deal
with this book I can't find anything
about it online I and what is going on
have you played these games and trust me
we had a lot of the same questions when
we first discovered these books actually
I brought for my house 3 the very first
three volumes that we actually found in
2014 it's a really interesting story
because when we first found these things
like we didn't even
know what we were getting into you know
but after starting to read them like we
noticed that there was like spare subtly
influencing kind of like all the videos
that we were making let's see
volume six has some great games in it a
small tiny guns was kind of influenced
by small and gay a game about shrinking
things down and shrinking yourself down
the titles are super rudimentary and
maybe the author didn't want to like
color you're experienced zombies was
good because actually there was a zombie
bull fighting moment airplane ride was
really really incredible because one you
start simulating flying in your mind you
get some really great ideas for drone
videos drone star wars kind of ended up
stemming from that Oh fight city
tactical reloads was kind of influenced
from that of this seedy underbelly of
police and criminals kind of end up
getting some really great weapon
fighting and reloading abilities in a
jungle primitive technology
well jungles basically you are trapped
in the jungle and you've got nothing to
live for and you've got nothing except
the skin on your back and you have to
survive so not the second tank video
with him alone with me along with the
first tank video I filmed with Danny
where I'm trying to sell him a tank army
was a huge part of that I think you're
getting into like a war zone thing it
really focuses on kind of more the
budgetary aspects and the management
parts of the army that you don't
normally think about and what we got
here volume 8 I remember this one time
machine I was reading this one before we
shot lifeline and it really helped me
get in that headspace of just
understanding how time travel works and
really kind of answers the question of
when someone is time-traveling from the
past to the future where are they
in-between if you play the game time
machine you you won't quickly find that
out
I still haven't played dancing it's
pretty incredible it's just a little bit
of taste of actually what's been kind of
going on behind the scenes here at
corridor digital over the last few years
yeah I mean it found it honestly we are
just really excited to finally start to
share this we didn't realize that until
we started giving these copies and
blending them around the studio how much
of an impact do to really have on
everyone's lives
I know Nick and Jake have both gotten
really into it to the point where
they've actually come to the studio with
stories they had in their dreams of
these games actually uh they were so
good that we wrote them in the
testimonial subsection at the end of
this book the really great little read
after you're done playing the games you
definitely don't read them before you
play Charles it kind of taints the
experience
[Music]